how many people here know I mean I've
heard about Raphael all right keep your
hands up if you've used drugs ql'
somehow and if now keep it up if you've
used it in production all right those
are just way too few hands because Groff
kale is really cool so you should
definitely check it out so let me tell
you a little bit about rough ql just
really quickly it's first of all it's an
alternative to rest so it's a different
way to fetch data from the server to the
client and it's it's a space-efficient
on the network because it's the client
that asks the server specifically what
information needs to be returned and so
it's not like you have a normal entry
point and you get a big blob of
information regardless you the client
can specify and so it's efficient on the
network but it also turns out to be a
really nice way to specify the data
requirements of your react components
and it's also turns out to be also a
nice way to organize the code on the
server so I will show you a little bit
of that later so this is what a query
looks like basically it's you know the
best way to describe it is just a JSON
without the values and so yeah so this
is the way a query looks like and the
response looks like you know they filled
up Jaisal so you get information back
from the server exactly what you asked
for
and so graph QL is built around three
major concepts one is a query which is
the way to read information from the
server one is a mutation which is a way
to write to a server and change the
server-side state of the application
kind of like a remote procedure call and
then the recent most recent edition is
subscription which is a way to for a
server to send push
notification push events to to the
client and just to make sure to be clear
graph QL is just a transport layer it's
just a way to exchange information data
with the server then you still have the
problem of dealing with the application
state and for that there are libraries
like relay or Apollo and since just a
couple of days to relay modern they just
announced the new version of relay and
they called it modern so now you have
relay classic and really modern it's 0
or 1.0 it's just a new version and these
libraries take care of allowing you to
specify the component their requirements
your or your react components and
dealing with the communication so you
don't have to refit if the server was an
answering for some reason and caching
most importantly so you know this is
just you know really quickly a really
quick introduction to what graph QL is
and in the ecosystem around it but do
look it up because it's really
interesting now back to the story of
this talk as I said I work about ceramic
and so you may know you may know our
tool which is a tool for creating
wireframes and this is typically a
desktop application what most people
knows us for but some of you may know
that we have an online version of it
that's called my balsamic
we've been bees in the past year and a
half well we rewrote the whole thing in
JavaScript because it used to be flash
so that's the biggest effort something
that my other colleagues are talking
about in other conferences also very
nice talks about how we will wrote the
whole thing but what I'm talking about
today is the effort of writing a new
online application
balsamic application which is this one
it's called balsamic cloud and it's
basically metadata containers it's a
place where you can put your Pacific
projects and so you have a way to store
your
projects and then if you click on the
project you can actually edit them with
the editor that you're familiar with in
the browser and then you can collaborate
on the project so you also have people
in your site so you have a site we have
people we have projects and then of
course we have site settings where you
can set you know the name of the site a
site can have multiple owners so it's
it's a that kind of application just you
know a container for projects so just to
give you a few numbers we're talking
about twenty-six thousand lines of code
but the actual editor you know the thing
that you can use for editing the
mock-ups in its 130k so you know not too
big not too small it's an interesting
size there are about thirty external
dependencies actual libraries that
provide some feature that we really
needed but then somehow we ended up
listing in package.json 150 modules
which blows up to a whuppin eight
hundred and sixty modules when you
install in node modules you know that's
the world we live in we all know that
two hundred react components spread
around 50 files 32 graphical mutations
so it's 32 different ways you can change
there on the server
25 events and then we have about 80%
coverage of the server-side code with
120 integration tests so this is our set
up and let's see a little bit about the
architecture so the whole thing runs on
AWS and in order to make sense of this
crazy set of services they provide we
use a tool that's called con Vox if you
don't know it look it up it's
interesting it's it's a nice way to make
sense of all the mess then we have a
graphical entry point of course that the
main entry point to our application
which builds on top of a schema so if
you don't know graph QL that's this what
you write a schema is what you write in
order to provide a feature
and then the resolvers of the schema hit
on the database is going through a
radius cache we make use we make heavy
use of the cache if it's warm and we
don't expect many many hits to the
database for a read operations and we
like to keep separate the definition the
part of the schema that defines we you
know properties that you want to read
from from the mutations which are the
you know the rights they have side
effects we like to keep them separate in
separate files it's nice to have you
know in your codebase a clear separation
of the portion of the code base that is
only read in the portion that is
side-effects another thing that we like
is just like in a good old C language
programming language where you have the
darhk file which describes the
implementation
similarly we like to separate the
mutations into the type definition
itself and separate it from the actual
implementation so we we call the
implementation operations because that's
what they do they operate on something
and we have it's nice to have them
separate also because not only can you
call them from the graphical entry point
but you can also call them from other
HTTP entry points which we do for
example when you you know accept an
invitation so you have a URL you click
and that's what happens on the server
side and your precious is actually where
the the real meet is of course that's
where we actually write to the database
or send an email or you know deal with
the payment process or send out
notification this kind of stuff so this
is the overall architecture and in
general it's been everything has been
developed according to the hexagonal
architecture which is a pattern if you
don't if you don't know it look it up
it's interesting it's basically a
pattern built around the concept that if
you have an external library an external
dependency you only ever import that
library in one module and that module
simply provides implements a little
wrapper
around the external library API to
provide an internal API so you make a
little point of indirection between your
code and the library so that if the
library change is you know upgrades or
whatever you figure out it's not
adequate you want to change it you only
have to rewrite the adapter and then the
rest of application keeps using the same
internal API it's really nice it works
worked really well for us we have about
19 adapters in cloud and we wrapped
everything from authentication cashing
database logging you name it so we don't
have we don't all of these dependencies
are only in one place in the code base
if you want to swap out the library for
one of those features we just replace
that single module and those adapters
are made available through the rest of
the application through dependency
injection so instead of relying on
import statements we mostly rely on
parameters being passed into functions
and these instances are made available
through the graphical context so let me
show you a little bit of code don't be
intimidated by this amount of code you
don't have to understand this also
because it looks very similar to what
you find in the in the in the examples
if we grab about graph QL basically it's
a type definition this is what is a
project in our schema and so you can see
a list of fields these are the fields
that are created there are accessible
through the graph QL schema and
basically this is just a way to define
the type and the resolver so in order to
get for example the thing that's called
properties there's a function that's
called a resolver and which is this one
and what you need just need to notice
here is that even though this is a
function it could have been like this
big we decided to make it list short
because of the same reason I said before
we like to keep the definition of the
type separate from the implementation so
inside the type definition we just place
one function call
and we just wrapped it with this little
thingy that we created it's called the
resolved with logger is just utility
function that intercepts
maybe exceptions and report them in a
nicer way than the you know barebone
library would have would have done
otherwise just utility so this is what
our type definition looks like this is
what a mutation looks like this is
indeed a little bit different than what
you see in the documentation of relay
for example because we leverage a naming
convention with this little helper
function up here we have as I said we
have a convention in our code base where
we like to keep the definition of the
type separate from the implementation
and we called implementation operations
so basically we have one directory that
contains JavaScript files called
mutations they contain JavaScript files
that define the mutations and then a
different directory called operations
with files of the same name
they contain implementation functions
and so this is you know as Mazyck as it
gets
we just leverage like leverage this
naming convention with that utility
function something useful we found to
write a little bit less code if there's
one thing that I've you know people
sometimes complain about relay in graph
QL is that it's a little bit verbose so
this is just a little way we found to
write a little bit less code this is
what an operation looks like again don't
try to make sense of it just notice that
these are the adapters
this is dependency injection right so we
pass a lot of adapters into the
functions because that's how we use them
down there so we just place method calls
on those adapters so for example you
will not see like SQL code in this
function because SQL belongs to the
realm of the database and so just like
everything else it's been wrapped in its
own adaptor it's nice to have one single
place in the code base with all this QL
there if you want optimize that's a
basic go so instead of having it
scattered around
so that's a that's a nice thing we we
found out this is another topic about
how we write these operations this is
just a couple of sanity checks that
throw errors and we learned that for
throwing errors instead of just raising
an exception we raise a little bit
smarter kind of exception that has three
pieces of information one is a simple
text for the user so something that
actually is shown in the UI and that's
used to indicate the next step it could
even be like write to customer support
you know so I shouldn't contain any
detail too not to scare the user away
and if also to not give away too much
information to malicious users so no
internal ID is nothing like that that
belongs to a second piece of information
a string that only goes to the server
logs there you must be as detailed as
possible because it you know it's useful
for debugging and then finally a unique
error code which is a string that goes
together with the first one to the
customer and we find this useful because
when they write support they cut and
paste the error and so it's nice for us
to see exactly in the code what
triggered the error we make sure that
these are unique so the next thing I
wanted to talk about is reactivity and
react reactivity reactive are all a very
popular words to study the meaning I'm
talking about today is when you're
looking at a site a page of an
application that contains information
and some of that information has changed
from another browser from another user
whatever you expect that page to update
right so this is the kind of things I'm
talking about so let's make an example
for example let's say that we want to
change the user of it I have two browser
tabs in my application and from one I
change my own a user avatar so I'm
expecting the other browser tab to
display the new image so how do how do
we go about doing that of course we need
some sort of
you know WebSocket to channel events
from the server right something like
that
so one naive way to approach that is
that you know the client sends a
mutation on my second on my second tab
to change the user avatar and then the
server changes the avatar and then sends
an event on the application channel that
my react components listen to so when
they mount they listen to these events
and when they see an event they
force-fed first Fett is the mechanism
from for relay to just reload force
reloading the information from the
server and it's a way to just you know
force updating everything so that of
course works because if you implement it
this way your whole application will
just reload the whole thing and so of
course it works then if you want to do
better then we can have more specific
events so instead of firing a generic
event we fire a user avatar changed
event so that our components can
actually listen so the user avatar
component will actually listen to the
user avatar changed event instead of
every possible event so that limits the
amount of force offenses another way is
to have narrower channels so instead of
having a generic application channel we
can have a user channel that's specific
to to myself and so that user avatar
changed event is sent through my user
channel and so only my only the user
avatar component will listen to that
channel and so that will also limit the
number of first fetches but if you start
to think about this in your application
this quickly becomes a hairy mess
because it's about the inherent
complexity of your application so for
example let's take a look at this page
as I said aside can have multiple owners
right and owners are also users so if
one of those users are so decided
specifically has to you two owners if
one of those users changes their name
I'm expecting this page to update right
so what does it look like so this is our
page you know simplified
as we said you know the user avatar is
just listening to the user channel if I
change user avatar on the server then I
fire an event on that channel and
therefore the user avatar updates now
talking about these two guys over here
these two combo boxes now they will have
to listen to the channel of the user
that are currently showing right and so
when on the server I get a change
username action mutation then I just the
server will just fire an event on the
channel of that user and that will solve
the problem because the UI can actually
update but then if you think about it
this is quite complicated on UI because
it means that those combo boxes will
have to listen to register to that
channel but then if I change the user on
the combo box
I have to deregister from the channel
register again to another user channel
it's it's good you know it's not very
nice so a better way to deal with this
is maybe maybe having maybe having on UI
a channel for the page for example and
so this is a site so we can have you
know a side channel for example and so
we can just assume that the server will
send that the relevant events will only
listen to that channel of course this is
pushing the complexity to the server now
because when I change the user name I
fire the event on the user channel but
if that user also happens to be an owner
of the site then I have to also send an
event on that site Channel right so you
see that we're just moving the
complexity from the UI to the server but
I claim that I think this kind of
complexity is better it's better to have
it on the server then in the UI it's
better to keep the UI simple so you know
just to wrap up about this completely
activity topic we know that relay
classic which is the relay that we have
out there doesn't provide any doesn't
write any solution out of the box you
have to write to you implement your own
thing pub/sub plus force-fed like we did
which is a solution but it's an
efficient because force FET is not a
nice way to deal with this
just because this there's just too many
round trips to the server you get the
event and then you go back to the server
to fats again so three round trips
instead of one Rene mortar in a Polish
that provide graphical subscriptions
which are a much better way to deal with
this because it's you can specify
exactly what events you want to listen
to and exactly what information you want
to get back from the server when these
events are fired
so it's an improvement over for spats
but it's kind of it's kind of new stuff
life queries is promising topic but it's
still not in discussion so we don't know
basically the bottom line is that if
this is an inherent complexity and you
somehow have to deal with it the tooling
that is out there that is getting more
and more mature is only helping us to
solve the UI part which is good but in
mind that this stuff is is complex
inherently complex now a couple of words
about testing something else we're
really happy about and we think that
graph QL is really well suited for so
our tests look like very simply mr. test
starts then we regenerate the whole
database on the real instance a local
instance of the database go through the
setup phases then we send up a graphical
request the server answers we check the
results and then go through a clean up
destroy the database and go on with the
next test so you would say you know this
could be quite expensive because it goes
through an actual database with real you
know the real code that hits the real
database in real cash we only mock the
external services like sending an email
or notifications and that kind of stuff
because we don't care about testing
those at the eyes but really this only
runs in two hundred milliseconds per
test and we have 120 tests that run in
less than 30 seconds for integration
testing this is really good we're really
happy and it gives us a lot of
confidence that we don't have major bugs
in the server so also look it up graph
QL is really good for testing
now we were really happy about this
project because it was starting from
scratch it was a greenfield project and
so the first thing we started to do was
look out you know what was available on
the space of the newer libraries one
year when a one year and a half ago when
we started and you find a lot of stuff
that plane you know you to be productive
with cool solutions like naming
conventions so that you have to write
less code default behaviors less
configuration automatic stuff here and
there like hashing and you don't have to
think about that and maybe you have an
or I am I don't know there's lots of
lots of interesting cool you know
libraries out there and frameworks that
there are real advanced because the
writing this stuff is not easy and
really cool but this all belongs to the
reality of magic and I don't like magic
because when I write something that I
want to maintain for a you know possibly
a long time I tend to forget the code
and especially the magic when I go back
to my code that I wrote six months ago
and there's some magic in it i neva
tably gets in the way so I'd rather
prefer the code to be unsurprising and
predictable as much as possible so you
know welcome boilerplate if that means
you know I will not be surprised
explicit configuration is good caching
is is a hard beast so you have to bite
the bullet and plain SQL why not
it's you know it much easier to to
optimize so this is all stuff that is
you know normally considered an
interesting and repetitive but it's safe
so I would rather go safe safe than
sorry so the bottom line I guess is you
have to be cool because you know
relaying graph QL and this kind of stuff
is really cool technology but play safe
you know adopt sound engineering
principles and yeah that was it thanks
[Applause]